[Music]
how i am here it's destiny
it's true i didn't think i'd take care of a
garden like this money was a
stage in painting and his garden we
are part of the actor claude monet
[Music  ]
so i came to work here on for
the restoration in 1976 everything was dead
so we had to start all over again i
had a plan to stay three or
four years but in the end
i'm still there despite my retirement
now it's  a garden that is very well known
and very popular with more than six hundred
thousand visitors in six months at the moment
we are ten full-time gardeners
I am retired for me it's easy
I live next door and so coming back to
the garden
the day begins  at 7am for
the summer not the winter because there is
no sun we live like the light
we repair what the visitors have broken
some by cutting the faded flowers and
it is very important we fertilize  we
water it's all the work of a
gardener
I'm 59 years old  s m
the risk is rather the flowers that
interested me and little by little I
learned to discover money so to love
it is very important to preserve this
garden because it marked the history
of painting the garden it has  been my
destiny
[Music]